jetzt zu unserem us komponenten herbert
bauernebel der dort vor den vereinten
nationen ist wo in diesem moment eine un
vollversammlung
stattfindet und herbert du hast gerade
dabei uns zu sagen warum das so
ungewöhnlich ist eine vollversammlung
ja wie gesagt das ist ganz ganz selten
ist erst elf mal in der geschichte der
vereinten nationen passiert und zum
letzten mal vor 40 jahren vor vier
jahrzehnten es ist eine art wie man das
veto umgehen kann im un sicherheitsrat
da gibt es bekanntlich fünf veto mächte
russland gehört dazu es gibt einen
sonder passus wo im sicherheitsrat
sicherheitsrat diese
generalversammlung einen notfall
generalversammlung einberufen kann mit
allen nationen und das ist praktisch ein
weg um am vetorecht vorbeizukommen diese
debatte hier hat begonnen mit
dramatischen appellen des uno
generalsekretärs am tod ihres ja gesagt
hat es tobt der krieg in der ukraine am
boden in der luft und zur see es muss
aufhören es muss gestoppt werden und
dass sofort ein dramatischer auf hofer
wie gesagt es sind hier alle nationen
mitgliedsnationen der der uno vertreten
jedes jedes land wird hier eine kurze
stellungnahme abgeben die ganze debatte
wird wahrscheinlich dauern drei tage
also bis zum mittwoch um dann dürfte es
eine resolution geben wahrscheinlich
gegen russland das ganze ist natürlich
symbolisch aber gleichzeitig sieht man
auch wie hier die ganze welt
offensichtlich jetzt zusammen steht
gegen russland gegen wladimir putin
dieser mann hat keine verbündeten mehr
in dieser welt es gibt nationen wie
china indien die sich hier vornehm
zurückhalten diplomatischen parkett aber
auch nicht bei russland aufstehen das
heißt jahre akt die welt rückt zusammen
gegen wladimir putin und das sieht man
hier auch vor den vereinten nationen in
new york wenn es am ende zu einer
resolution kommt unter sozusagen über
den umweg dieser vollversammlung das
veto russlands im un-sicherheitsrat
umgangen werden könnte was bedeutet das
dann aber konkret welche auswirkungen
hat das dann
wie gesagt es ist eine eher symbolische
akt mit einer verabschiedung der
resolution wäre russland dann verurteilt
von der welt für seine gräueltaten in
der ukraine aber dass man parallel hört
sind auch überlegungen letztendlich den
weg zu bereiten das war gut ihn
letztendlich sogar vor einem
kriegsgericht landen könnte von baxter
international kriegsrecht in den hacker
die amerikanische un-botschafterin
länder thomas greenfield hat sich
diesbezüglich geäußert hat gesagt alle
optionen sind auch den auf dem tisch des
ganzes netz oder durch szenarien für die
zukunft geht es den diplomaten hier eine
lösung zu finden um der ukraine zu
helfen und um den krieg zu stoppen
du hast vorhin gesagt herr china und
indien halten sich momentan noch vornehm
zurück china spielt ja eine ganz ganz
wichtige rolle
letzte meldung aus dem chinesischen
außenministerium waren dass man die
westlichen sanktionen gegen russland
verurteilt andererseits stellt man sich
auch nicht wirklich an die seite welche
möglichkeiten hat der westen die usa so
beiden oder auch deutschland jetzt auf
china einzuwirken auch china könnte sich
jetzt in eine neue position rücken und
sozusagen auf die gute seite herüber
wechseln
so ist es man könnte die den krieg diese
kräuter bild diese horror bilder die uns
was die minuten tag erreichen aus der
ukraine dazu nutzen und versuchen china
auf die auf die westliche seite ein
wenig zu ziehen oder zumindest einen
größeren abstand gewinnen zu lassen
gegenüber moskau china natürlich
hat ebenfalls interesse große interesse
die wirtschaft ist eng verflochten mit
dem westen von china peking spürt jetzt
auch und ist möglicherweise sogar ein
wenig überrascht wie einheitlich die
reaktion und wie scharf die reaktion des
westens auf den russischen überfall auf
die ukraine
passiert ist und könnte auch eine
warnung sein für peking selbst das
sollte china etwa einen alleingang wagen
gegen taiwan das china als abtrünnige
provinz bezeichnet dass auch hier der
westen derart h einige zusammenstehen
kann andrea zurückschlagen kann das ist
wirklich einen unterschied macht und das
ist wahrscheinlich die größte
beobachtung und die größte lektion die
peking gerade zieht aus dem jetzigen
drama herbert bauernebel vor den
vereinten nationen wo in diesem moment
eine ja fast schon historische sitzung
stattfindet eine un vollversammlung es
elf mal hat es das gegeben in der
geschichte dass eine solche große
versammlung adhoc herr einberufen werden
könnte vielen dank herr werte für deine
äußerungen